うわぁ
[音楽]
沖縄にいますもう行かなきゃいけないんだよなただ300でなきゃいけないんで
ちょっと準備しながら説明しましょう皆さん沖縄と北海道の何が違うと思いますからも
つの転機とのも違うと思うんですけどもなんか色々調べたところですね
今回
で同機能だと体重に違いが出るらしいですよ強くないか同じ日本で言うのに体重計で
体重ハドルと北海道届けのはだと名指しないけど微妙に体重に変化が出るらしい
これこれすごいなぁと思いましてテクでも沖縄にいるんでもうこの検証する機会なんて
そうそうないと思うんですよ北海道系なんていいキスもじゃないじゃないですかこんな
こんなのが沖縄へ
に変えたらとかなんですけどもこんな機会は二度とないということで
今日は急遽今日はなんと生で品準備で止め二時間がないんだなちょっと片付けます
とりあえず
矢部遅刻だよ
そういうわけで今日は大きな輪に入るんですけどもう本会同人って沖縄と北海道と体重
が本当に変化するのか私を実際に使っていった仕組みでみたいと思いますておきながら
北海道イクして飲んでそうなんでしょうか早速行きましょう
それというのも突っ込んだこれをだけど叩きはここで書道家に会しまーす入ったばい
ばーい
ばいばーい
みんなといると強気なんですけど
飛距離だと本当にやばい入ってきて北海道行の飛行気を付けたが出来ました
ドイツ語版も飲み物もあるとと入りしてこよ
はいというわけで8別トイレを済ませてきましたでご飯も食べました飲み物を飲みまし
た大きなはから北海道までの飛行ての間僕は一切体重を減らさないようにします食べ
ない飲まない排出しないつだとかもはかない
はなくても出さない涙も流しません汗もかけません完全な無心の状態で完全にこの質量
を維持したまま北海道にいい
て体重を量ってみたいと思いますして皆さん大きなは西十何キロなんでしょうか
いただきます
ていた
[音楽]
俺1ターン
沖縄は73.9 k です
22は結構太ったん
[音楽]
分
30,000おっというわけで北海道つきました
千歳空港ということなんですけども完全に北海道ですねはい
北海道に来ましたちょっと完全に服装がヤバイですよ皆さんがなんかダウンジャケット
とかコート着てるところ僕これですからね
まじでやばいすごさっすが図っていきましょう本当に無心で言って気も併せ持つばも
はかず大きなはから北海道に来ました
さっきは73.9距離だったんですけども果たして
何キロになっているのでしょうか
大さっと全く同じ状態ですグッ
[音楽]
ぬじーさんって8位子500g 減ってます
誤差やはいというわけでわざわざ体重を計るために沖縄から北海道に行ってきました時
で沖縄で測った時は73点90キログラム
北海道で測ったときは服上衣を着てた時でも
73.85kg ちょっと軽くなってたわけですね北海道の方がうわ市でたのに麻里子
さだと思うんですけど一応検証的には体重が変動したんですよね
沖縄方が重くて北海道の方が軽かったでこれ同じ日本なのになんで体重にこんなさんが
起きればいいますと調べたんですよ
なんでかと言いますと重力っていうのはですねいいの井戸っていうのが高くなるほど
重くなっていくらしいんですよ
日本国内では沖縄が最もかっ
軽く
北海道は最も重い逆だなを
えっ
これなかっただけ沖縄の方が重くてと北海道も軽かったのよなんかで言ったてみたら
北海道の方が重く
沖縄の方が軽いて帰ったというのは沖縄の方が重くてほかやの軽かったんですけど
[音楽]
俺な日にッターン
me
あっはぁ